[Applause]
no Newcastle fan wanted to miss out on
this
first Wembley final this Century but
they land the first major trophy in 68
years you net tens of thousands they
came in Hope
Madison they lost hope of experiencing
again
[Applause]
it's under Saudi ownership and more than
200 million pounds in transfers has
transformed the magpies
if only their early chances had found
the net
they weren't facing a Manchester United
side also a sergeant
If Only They Weren't relying on a
goalkeeper playing for the first time in
two years
this a stretched too far for loris
carius
a second
[Applause]
Marcus rashford shot
deflation fell from The Terraces
to the tine
pressure how could they turn it around
came about damage limitation
comes onto it
[Applause]
final ending in a two-nil defeat
so no first domestic cup since 1955 for
Newcastle but with Saudi backing surely
it won't be decades again before the
club is back in a final for now it's
Manchester United celebrating the end of
a trophy drought after six years
Newcastle hope this will soon be them
but it's Manchester United with the
League Cup
dreaming of bigger prizes again
Rob Harris Sky News Wembley